اذا قبل قليل همم على ما يبدو القبه
الحديديه اعترضت صواريخ فوق غلاف غزه بعد
ان كنت همم قد طبعا افدت بانه صفاره
الانذار كانت تدوي في عسقلان ومستوطنات
غلاف غزه صف لنا المشهد لديك
راويه كما كان متوقعا حقيقه بعد مجزره
جنين
كانت هددت بالرد وعمليا بدا هذا الرد
باطلاق عدد من الصواريخ تجاه مدينه
قطاع غزه على الاقل جاره اعتراض صاروخين
فوق مدينه السلام
المنطقه همم ربما ايضا اصدق الصراحه
يتم اعتراضها ايا كان هذا توقع في خلال
ربما وقت قصير جدا
ايضارات اسرائيليه عجيبه على مواقع عسكريه
تابعه لحماس والجهاد الاسلامي في قطاع غزه
هذا الامر متوقع جدا ان يحدث همم بشكل همم
الصواريخ التي تم اعتراضها كانت فوق
عسقلان تحديدا هل هناك اي انباء عن اي
صواريخ
يعني امم استطاعت ان تصيب اي من الاهداف
التي همم وضعت لها
عندما نقول اعتراض راويه هذا يعني بان
الصواريخ كانت في طريقها للاصابه المباشره
همم القبه الحديديه تعترض الصواريخ التي
تذهب الى المناطق الماهوله او المناطق
العسكريه همم عددا همم وبالتالي عطاردها
همم هناك همم حتى الان لا معلومات يعني كل
ما نتحدث عنه الان والمعلومات الاوليه همم
بعد دقائق من اطلاق الصواريخ ولكن
الوضع متوتر للغايه على جبل قطاع غزه
حاليا كما قلت التوقعات ان تقوم اسرائيل
بشمهارات على مواقع التابعه لحمامات
والجهاز الاسلامي همم ايضا سبقه هذه
المواقع وايضا مواقع الرفض القريبه من
الحدود يعني هذا كان مؤشر همم
تبادل القبض على جبل قطاع غزه
كان مساله وقتها هذا فعلا مدد طيب يعني
بعد مجزره جنين تسعه فلسطينيين تم قتلهم
من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه في اقتحام مخيم
جنين هل من المرشح ان يتزايد الوضع همم
تصعيدا يعني بان يعني يتجه لمواجهه مفتوحه
كالتي يعني اعقبت ما حصل في الشيخ جراح
طبعا ولكن عمليا الان بما سيحدث على جبل
قطاع غزه تحديدا
حصر الصواريخ في منطقه غلاف غزه بمعنى من
حدود وحتى 30 كم عن تلك الحدود هذا يبقى
قابلا للاحتواء تدخل مصري سريع عاده يمكن
ان يحتوي الموقف لكن اذا التطور مدى
الصواريخ لاحقا او اذا استمر على الاقل
اطلاق الصواريخ في الساعات المقبله عمليا
والبدى كان اعمى العمده الاسرائيلي هدف
يعني يوسع دائره ال ال الوججه على جبهه
قطاع غزه ايا كان ايضا اسرائيل مستنفره
تماما في الضفه الغربيه المحتله وفي القصه
الشرقيه وحتى على حدود لبنان وسوريا جرار
رفع حالتاه خشيه من اطلاق صواريخ بعد
مجزره جنين في المداولات الامنيه التي
اجراها نتنياهو مع وزير الدفاع وقاده
الجيش اليوم ولد عمليا بشكل واضح محاوله
الامتناع
رجعت اضافيه في القصه الغربيه المحتله في
محاوله لاحتواء الموقف لان اسرائيل الان
ايضا لا تريد
الضفه الغربيه بالكامل قبل ايام فقط من
اصول بنت الوزير خارجيه امريكا الى
اسرائيل ولا اراضي الفلسطينيه
زياد حلبي مراسل العربيه كان معنا من
القدس شكرا لك